big changes are coming for millions of
Americans with student loans today the
White House announcing it is extending
the pause in student loan repayment for
the one last time this year canceling
now thousands of dollars worth of loan
for borrowers who make under 125 000 a
year joining us on this issue
maheshadrani a financial expert with
Strategic Wealth design Mahesh thanks
again for being here thank you for
having me first question let's get into
it is there anything borrowers need to
do with their accounts considering it's
been for many two years of no activity
on so many of these accounts correct for
since 2020 they've not had any
repayments or interest accumulate under
sorted loans that repayment has extended
once more until December 31st but now
starting January they will have to pick
up payments so at this point for the
next several months they should start
planning and making sure they have a
they have the appropriate budget and
cash flow to pay to start making those
payments in January and this is only for
loans taken out prior to June of 2021
right it's for future student loans for
kids trying to afford very expensive
college it doesn't apply to them correct
in terms of the affordability of college
the future loans well you make a good
point when you say it could we don't
know if this could be forgiven for
students in the future as well correct
we don't know what the I mean we know
what the bill has written today sure we
don't know what future action Congress
is going to take to forgive further
loans or reduce the cost of college but
you are correct this does not impact
future loans and we're talking about 10
000 for individual borrowers we're
talking about 20 000 for Pell Grant and
then the salary for a married couple
goes up to 250 000 okay 250 000. now
Senator Ted Cruz made some remarks today
after President Biden's announcement
saying taxpayers will be faced with that
big Bill take a listen
I think it is unfortunate to see him
spending
billions of dollars which is going to
drive inflation even worse what
President Biden has in effect decided to
do is to take from Working Class People
to take from truck drivers and
construction workers thousands of
dollars of taxes in order to
redistribute it to college graduates who
have student loans
all right question then where is all
this money coming from to pay for this
large amount of student loan debt at the
end of the day the taxpayers are going
to pay for it it's almost estimated
about 300 billion dollars is what's
going to cost in terms of forgiveness
and at the end of the day someone's
going to be holding that bag and it's
going to be the taxpayers appreciate the
straight answers from you great
information there in a brief amount of
time we appreciate it and also to figure
out how much of your loan will be
forgiven log into your federal student
aid account your dashboard should show
you a breakdown with this chart it will
likely differentiate the amount in your
loans and grants like you see right
there in the screen and there will be
further details for you as well